community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
findlay automotive group the sponsors of
this next segment are raising money for
a very special organization in a fun way
we stop by finley toyota to learn more
and meet one of their best buddies
[Music]
so we're here at findlay toyota today
and we're talking about best buddies
which is a great charity that we love to
support we're supporting them for a long
time and what they do
is they provide opportunities and
friendships and help arrange employment
for people with intellectual
developmental disabilities
and
that's how we met michelle who works for
us here at findlay toyota she came to us
through best buddies and so we're trying
to help them out she came to me not too
long ago and wanted me to be run for the
champion of the year compete for
champion of the year which is a
fundraising competition
i looked at michelle i couldn't say no
to her so i'm running for champion of
the year and we're going to raise money
to help best buddies and we're going to
win and uh and thanks to michelle we're
going to have a good time doing it when
i met tyler he said he wanted me to book
at one of his dealerships
and with
best buddies
i got a job
i've been working here almost four years
he understands
people with special needs
just like me he's an amazing guy
and they love him and i know it makes
good he is going to win champion affair
so all the fundraising leads up to the
gala the champion of the year gala on
november 5th so between now and then
we're going to do a bunch of stuff to
raise money we're getting our employees
involved all of our dealerships involved
we're actually going to do a dunk tank
so they've talked me into getting in a
dunk tank so people that
don't like me very well can come and
throw a ball and dunk me in the tank so
that'll be fun we're gonna try to get
everybody we we work with our vendors
and our suppliers and so forth involved
do everything we can to raise money for
best buddies through best buddies
i got a best buddy
a friend
i felt isolated
and that's why i got this job and i feel
more confident thank you for calling me
philly tyola this is michelle speaking
how can i help you michelle does a great
job for she does a lot of data entry for
us and greets our customers
everybody that comes into the store and
sees michelle it brightens their day as
you can tell you know i love working
here in spain toyota
everyone
ever ever is
so funny to me
and i feel like i am part of the philly
family team
and i thank you so much for the bottom
of my heart and this is my second home
and i love everyone
why am i now in tears we love michelle
michelle you're amazing if you've been
to findlay toyota you walk in and she's
the first one to greet you and she is so
sweet i'm crying head to
bestbuddieschampion.org to help tyler
win and tell me when that dunk tank is
going down las vegas now we'll be right
back